we're going to do two different ideas
today but each of them as I was
listening to something before is a
continuation of some precipitation we do
step it up it becomes more challenging
as your seed shortly
yesterday we've had this idea of taking
an inequality something like this and
representing it visually and I'm going
to reach it we've taken one dimensional
inequality put them on the number line
you like are just this part or it's like
this part or whatever so you've got two
dimensions here you need to coordinate
actions you need two dimensions for your
two variables and that's why we use the
Cartesian plane so before we have a look
at what this heading is about really
wonderful qualities let's just revise
that what is this like where you've just
got one way is greater than or equal to
X where I gave you a rule of thumb
I've got always exactly Chuke Sanam be
careful whatever be but I gave your
rules come with Y with the topic what
should we say about this Y is just going
to be above or equal to or equal to this
equation here we know exactly one else
but let's go ahead and draw some it will
be critically important every time to
enable your hands are so then with your
equations I try to add a solid line
because it's inclusive and you told me
it was about was bad so I'm ready to
change this time yeah
so this green shaded section here every
single point is there satisfies the
inequality Y is greater than or equal to
x squared so far so good
y is less than X boxer this is easier
than one before I've done if you're a
straight line of my boundary
ex-prostitute you've noticed I've dotted
because in this case weighs less than so
it's not in Christopher's the boundary I
should lead to more equations and
because less there's or which side am I
going to shame I'm going to shade
beneath or you could take to the right
but it's not helpful to say above or
below because that's really what these
inequalities like these Y value
inequalities are about to multiply so I
was going to show them okay now this
heading I've written multiple
inequalities is what happens when you
say well what about if you consider both
of these at the same time considered
voted at the same time there's two
different ways to do this and I'd like
you to make a little subheading for each
one so the first one is what we call the
intersection of ridges
when you have two different regions that
overlap in some way when you are asked
for the intersection of those two
regions what that means is where are
these both true at the same time let me
say that again the intersection means
both at the same time the word that you
will see attached to this is the word
and I want this to be true and I also
want this to be true simultaneously so
I'm going to write each of these and I'm
going to put an end between them now do
you remember when we were dealing with
one-dimensional inequalities and
sometimes you would find the answer to
something would be lots of different
pieces there will be multiple something
like there yeah if you were solving this
when you solve this guy because your
Social Security is quadratic you should
be able to see oh I don't know the shape
of this I know where it's going to
intersect with the axes so therefore X
is going to be less than negative 3 or
it's going to be X is greater than
negative 2 that's to the left that's the
right yeah ok and I made a big deal
about saying it's all or because there's
no number there's no good thing you can
put it to X that satisfies both those
inequalities at the same time right but
when you have a look at these there are
quint on the plane clearly terrible
there are points on the plane that
Jewish survivors in so I can put an T as
if paper and then you want over them now
I'm going to draw up a new set of
quantities with these two other but I
want to unworn you wanna warn you
even though please no in fact just put
your pen down and look up at this is
such a weak idea even though this
inequality includes the boundary when I
draw the boundary down here on this
graph which includes both reasons on
this one
I'm only going to draw daughters in fact
no matter what I've got I'm going to
draw bosses some that I may or may not
fill in in a minute but you'll see why
shortly okay so I'm going to draw the
boundary of this I'll draw a diet or
goes on value.this I'm also going to
draw a dollar and then I'm going to try
to figure out what when any vote true so
go ahead on our new third turkeys draw
both together now that wasn't too
difficult to do because you've just
drawn them before so you know what these
look like
notice that I've labeled the equations
and remember by the way y equals x plus
2 is a straight line
it's the boundary of white less than X
plus 2 this like you know they want is
not Y is less than X plus 2 it's a line
that's y equals I can I think I want
both of these to be true the same time I
want to be above the parabola and I want
to be below the straight line I want to
be above the parabola abalos straight
line there's one small region where both
of those are true the same time you see
where it is in between pot in it so I'm
going to have this part here
do you see that part is the part that's
gross underneath em up right underneath
the straight line above the problem
there we've got the basic idea here but
there are two things which I want to now
be a little more precise on firstly and
I pointed this out with that same circle
that we did yesterday unlike these guys
here which sort of stretch on forever
this region here has beginning and end
points on its it's edges right
specifically this part over here and
also this part over here okay yeah see
carefully with me firstly we should find
out where these lectures are how am I
going to find out where those
coordinates are gonna tell you what it
is okay their question intersection what
do I do
algebraically to get appointment
intercession I'm going to solve
simultaneously so I have one equation I
have the other let's go ahead and solve
so I think it's going to be helpful for
you because you'll have like working
attached to this tell me what you're
doing so I'm going to say find points of
intersection so I'll join two
conveniently I've got both of them and
with Y in the subject so I can just get
rid of the Y's and say x squared will
equal X plus 2 x squared will equal X
plus 2 so I get this what would you like
to do with this I can factor out this
what's the factorization X minus 2 X
plus 1
yep that's right that's what I expected
so that's equal to 0 so what that
talking thank you negative 1 will be one
of those positions or x equals 2
positive 2
ok now remember I'm searching for
coordinates right I'm searching for
coordinates so I've got the x values I
would also like the Y values to go with
them right so when X is equal to
negative 1 what's Y believe
just what isn't it and when X is equal
to two Y sorry to be four three and you
can't elemental check to see that both
of these will fit bunch of pipe lines
2.50 why don't you take hands my
suppression creep I suppose you could
actually though I shouldn't now suppose
the reason why I've done it here is
because I think value of x copy both of
these at the same time so that's why
I've just said all but in this case it
doesn't make as much of an instrumental
difference of this where as you'll see
in a minute when I don't talk about the
intersection becoming else putting all
here actually make a difference whereas
here I just want the two points okay
I've got enough information for
coordinate canal so I'm going to label
this guy negative one one ml a black eye
to four okay now I want to ask are these
points in the region do they satisfy
remember both of the inequalities at the
same time let's just look at this one
once 1 1 then minus 1 1 satisfy existing
the comity another minus 1 1 it does
govern it because 1 is greater than or
equal to 1 it's the kids with equal to
me what about here does minus 1 1
satisfy this one it doesn't and actually
you knew that if given already before
testing anything because in the first
case you drew this done it right so
therefore this is going to stay hollow
by the same kind of logic what's going
to happen over here will be still below
it will also be hollow because you need
both at the same time which is why this
one out doesn't matter what this one is
this one already says up again anywhere
on this boundary will not be included in
your region so I don't include either
okay now last part you've dealt with the
points of intersection now I want to
look at the boundaries that are relevant
okay can you see this area is confined
by this straight line and this portion
of the parabola do you notice that the
straight line we already know is not
going to be included in a boundary how
do I already know that
yes they just looked at the original one
right and it was included there so you
just leave it done
the parabola on the other hand part of
the padlock should be included right
this part underneath here is include and
you can take any value there say zero
zero that's on the parabola right you
can test it out and sure enough it will
do this one and this one right what do
you notice
and this is why I asked you to draw the
parabola dotted at the beginning even
though it says there's the batteries
included not all the brothers included
right probably going to point up here
why is it a point like this so you can
predict them
why isn't the X part of the reason
that's for there is not part of the
region because even more satisfies this
it doesn't at the same time satisfy this
right it clearly way above that line
which is switches out okay this is a
little bit weird you fill in part of
that battery but not the whole thing
which is why I leave these guys of it is
that at any moment